hello there I'm Nick and I'm gonna play
will Nick lick it a game in which I am
handed something very gross on a stick
and I have to either lick it or answer a
very personal question about myself this
is a hot cheeto dipped in coffee
I'll take the question please what is
the last thing I lied to my wife about
[Music]
mmm usually when I tell an untruth to my
wife it's too because I'm worried that
she'll not be able to get to sleep or
something like if it's some kind of bad
news
we call it the sin of omission I
recently withheld some information about
the wildfires in California I chose not
to tell her until the next day that they
were closer than comfortable to our
house so that she could sleep through
the night
not very salacious I still haven't told
her about my secret family in Tulsa and
I'd appreciate if we could keep that
between us I made the right choice
that's a gross ass soggy cheetah this is
a slim jim covered in butter
I'm not gonna look that thing was the
most annoying co-star on Parks and Rec I
guess jean-ralphio played by Ben
Schwartz because that's his flavor every
character has their superpower his is to
be annoying that's how he's funny
by design he is the most annoying and
he's incredibly good at it that's why
he's so funny which is even more
annoying I'm not this is this is a
daytime show so I'm just gonna hand that
back oh this is the the last item is a
twizzler soaked in hot sauce
[Music]
I'll lick that son of a buck
good game this has been will Nick flick
it see you next time let me know how
Nicolas Cage does I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this